hi
oh my God
I'm watching you in your new series
poker face and
you guys it is
the best show it's like Matlock it's 70s
it's like Agatha Christie it's like
really hot you're like you've got this
wild sex appeal in it and you're like an
old movie star where you cannot stop
staring at you it's so beautifully shot
so beautifully acted an insane cast of
like just take a look
ah
Grace man you too
all that loss and you keep moving
forward living your lives
forgive and forget right oh sweetie no
never
okay so Maya Rudolph is the co-ep yeah
you are the executive producer how did
you guys meet and like did you have
chemistry did you guys think alike how
did that all come about
yeah so Maya and I uh we met it's got to
be like 20 years ago and we're in like a
a fashion situation in Midtown and then
we just walked 50 blocks together
downtown and sort of cemented this what
would become a permanent forever
friendship and then she'd be on SNL and
I'd be there kind of most weekends just
in her room and then Sunday brunch you
know I mean it'll be only like four
hours later but we do it I always look
back now and I I feel like we bought the
same really large sofa at ABC Furniture
which makes me realize like just how
tight we work because it's such a weird
thing to do but I think we just like
doing things together and kind of you
know what I mean I do and now
um Switching gears a little bit you were
with my baby Aubry Plaza is my baby now
and I'm her mommy
[Applause]
um
I'm the daddy you guys were thinking did
we make a baby
[Applause]
and that's it that's how babies are born
that's exactly that's how babies are
born isn't our daughter doing so well
thriving I'm so proud of her she did
such a good job such a good job she's on
top of the world too yeah she's a little
cutie wait
is it true that when you were asked to
do American Pie kicking it back to when
we were teenagers is it true that they
asked you like multiple times to do it
and what were you why why did you say no
at first and what and eventually made
you say yes well I think that I just
sort of saw it on paper and I didn't
identify with this
sort of like very very white very normal
high school experience
oh we're going to lose our virginity I
was like honey it already happened like
yeah
so I like the whole movie
guys just just do it you know
hey you know you'll figure it out later
in life and uh anyway so yeah just only
I understood the movie but uh then they
gave me money and then I began to
understand yeah
foreign
I always went for the avant-garde one I
never went for the popular All-American
I was like Tom Green Eddie K Thomas like
yeah the 90s were a whole thing uh they
really really were well Jennifer
Coolidge who ends up getting it on with
Eddie K Thomas in the movie Stifler's
mom is talk about having a moment can
you believe she's just thriving
and she said in her Golden Globe speech
that she would be game for another
American Pie movie would you be like
listen now I'm at an age where anywhere
Jennifer Coolidge goes I go
right I think now American Pie could be
made into a really cool Indie with like
really cool actors because it's all
comes full circle and we can do this you
know American Pie
other things yeah on the projects the
real slice yeah
[Applause]
I want to see if there was ever to be an
American Pie reboot I feel like
everybody's in this extraordinary place
too that like how would that not be the
coolest movie sure why not you know get
it while you can as Janice Joplin says
Get it while you can yes yes indeed yeah
all right well we have to go to a quick
commercial break but we're going to be
right back with Natasha Leone
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]